si vous voulez je vais parler de
l'avortement même adressé à l'avocat
plutôt qu'à la femme je vous demanderais
si
cette loi
est améliorée a dit l'avortement devient
libre pour toutes
et si un jour vous vous trouvez en
présence d'une femme qui vient de tuer
son enfant de quelques jours de quelques
mois
et qu'est ce que vous allez faire
en cette femme
alors que vous donner l'absolution à
celle qui aura tué son enfant dans son
vin
cc c'est une contrainte moi j'y retrouve
oui moi je trouve que
m'excuse de le dire mais il faut
vraiment le répéter je ne répèterai
autant de fois que j'en aurais la force
pour que ça soit dit une fois pour toute
et compris et nous ne faisons pas de
croisade pour la voix rendement
nous nous battons pour que les femmes
soient libres de choisir leur maternité
ça c'est fondamental
et l'important wiiu madame c'est que si
moi je suis libre de choisir vos mets
maternité vous avec les conceptions que
vous aurez que j'ignore mme que je crois
deviner quelles que soient vos
convictions philosophiques religieuses
morales vous aurez comme moi le droit de
choisir je veux dire que si vous
entendez ne jamais avoir tes et avoir un
enfant chaque fois que vous aurez un
rapport sexuel c'est votre affaire ce
qui est intolérable c'est que vous ayant
fait ce choix oubliée la prétention de
l'imposer aux autres et la deuxième
chose que je veux dire c'est pourtant le
débat qui a lieu aujourd'hui dans le
pays c'est pas autre chose une loi qui
libéralise l'avortement en deuxième
mieux car je tiens aussi à signaler que
dans la proposition de loi que choisir a
élaboré en tant que travail puisque
choisir est un mouvement une association
apolitique n'a pas de député mais cette
proposition était reprise par le parti
socialiste le titre numéro un c'est la
contraception et l'éducation sexuelle
alors je voudrais bien qu'aujourd'hui on
nous rendent un peu justice toutes
celles et tous ceux qui comme vous se
sont battus contre la contraception
contre l'éducation sexuelle on peut dire
que nous avons au moins remporter ce
succès là l'éducation sexuelle il me
semble qu'on le met en place peut être
pas très bien d'ailleurs enfin ça vient
la contraception je n'ai pas trouvé
moins d'adversaires d'un contraception
en tout cas aujourd'hui on vous dit oui
la contraception mais pas l'avortement
mais soyons logiques l'ultime recours si
un échec il faut bien permettre à une
femme d'avoir les enfants qu'elle désire
et la deuxième chose que je voulais dire
parce qu'elle me paraît aussi importante
encore que je là encore je le répète
sans arrêt c'est qu'il ya un abus de
langage une escroquerie que je dois dire
en tant que maire je parle en tant que
maire et que femme et parce que vous
séparer pour moi faire une mère femme
avocate militante politique tout ça
c'est la même chose je ne suis pas
tiroirs je suis un être humain que je
voudrais je voudrais être à part entière
il voit toutes les femmes soient et
venait pas de cloisonnement donc ma
bataille c'est la même je n'ai pas
changé alors je trouve que vous n'avez
pas le droit de dire que lorsqu un
spermatozoïde rencontre par hasard un
ovule il ya un enfant c'est une
escroquerie fondamentale l'enfant non
c'est la vie biologique madame s'est
lavé ce qui est certain par exemple je
vous pose la question est ce que les
femmes il va y en avoir d'ici au débat à
l'assemblée il va y avoir quelques 200
femmes qui vont mourir les statistiques
sont là des femmes qui vont tenter de
savoir d clandestinement parce qu'elle
préfère mourir que d'avoir des enfants
qu'elles n'ont pas souhaité avoir ça
vous le savez c'est 200 femmes va mourir
alors si vous engagez vous employez ce
langage de vie par exemple est ce que
ces femmes ont bien une vie oui ça se
discute pas qui est criminel
celui qui tue la vie bat laura qui en
l'espèce qui tue ses 200 femmes d'hommes
en l'espèce qui tue ses deux sans fin
pourquoi dans l'oeuf je vous aime
quelque chose de plus concret je vous
donne des femmes comme vous et moi
structuré existence la route qu'il faut
que celle-ci elles sont tuées par quoi
par une loi qui véritablement le moyen
hinges pour la france c'est le moyen âge
plus de la moitié du monde plus de la
moitié du monde pratiquent l'avortement
libre et je vous assure que dans ces
pays il a vraiment on peut dire que
c'est un ça n'est pas du tout la
conséquence d'un choix politique ou
d'une économie ça peut être la chine ou
les états unis où lurs mais je vous
assure que d'autres que dans ces pays là
on n'a pas l'impression que on a une
régression on n'a pas l'impression qu'on
revient au crématoire on n'a pas la
pression non plus qu'on retourne à la
barbarie au contraire le niveau de vie
s'élève et les femmes prennent de plus
en plus conscience de ce qu'ils
fondamentale une femme doit commencer
pas avoir le pouvoir sur elle même si
seulement quand j'ai le pouvoir sur moi
que je sais que je peux affronter le
reste et les autres si je sais que je
peux être cassé dans un accident un
avortement comme nous en avons eu tout
je crois peut-être pas vous madame et
les femmes qui m'écoutent savent que où
elles ont avorté où elles ont une soeur
ou mer ou ou dans la famille ou une amie
qu'elle ont secourus chacun sait que
l'avortement est un drame quotidien
[Musique]